hello way to welcome to this video
playing p way p way come on english yes
which line do we get so yeah it is going
for the cop off yeah for the combo
system like III here then ii a three and
then III another tongue twisting here
yeah i'm getting d4 in i can do it now
delay it a bit never quite sure if why
should go d for in such a position one
and sometimes slow approach with d3 and
before is also quite good this is them
in general a very positive side of the
english opening it is fairly flexible
you cannot really say that it's just
like one idea and in many positions in
fact oftentimes you have a multitude of
ideas which makes it an interesting
practical choice p 8 quite sure what is
afraid of there between
[Music]
well see i wanted to hear with this h 3
i'm going to prevent on a piece coming
to reform yeah that's a typical way to
play this night coming to f5 mmm yeah c5
is a very normal way to play this might
just go be six
not sure that I want to do this yet
often we get something with d5 and then
see 5 and black tries to bring ass
Bishop around with c 6 and so on but
rupee aid isn't exactly ideal for that
so we'll see what it does you can also
play a bishop at five or nine f5 in this
position well if it's quite likely
action but a cannon I c 6-r it the many
many possible options c6 I go see five
that data oh he does it okay yeah this
I'm pretty happy with you should f4 is
some an idea now yeah and then this
should be nice actually I can play
Bishop f4 but I can also do that next MO
maybe not it maybe not 96 but okay it
seems nice anyway with this bishops
stuck on a seven maybe just 96 no
doesn't do that
[Music]
it looks comfortable quite comfortable
down with the black Bishop being
somewhat stop we in trades okay so he
wants to play we should be 80 Bishop is
six and then but should be aids us this
kind of thing
I go look in one you probably will play
Bishop insects
[Music]
taking it Andrew t7 that's actually no
guess quadruped f7 okay that's really
important otherwise that would be pretty
strong already I'm hmmm contemplate each
point Bishop e3
what G for f1 it also is interesting but
should be aight i will take and go fy5
pushing the bishop of ways when I can go
to e7 not sure this is fantastic but
King 23 no so pretty direct approach
see doing a bishop c8 that that looks
that would look very passive really yeah
it still doesn't yeah maybe it maybe it
also mean maybe it does hmm taketake
rookie 79 I don't know if it does that
much
well and if I go g5 time work I'm not
taking at five year yes wow I thought
that this wouldn't work out really
giving me Jesse six oh shoot no come on
when did I allow this bloody tactic I'm
tomorrow from this fantastic position
really I have to go to f3 now just back
to g1 well that would have been almost
ought to make one also dramatically I
think on the on the queenside
yeah those pawns will promote they
definitely promote check I only have two
seconds check my god check check white
fortunes on a Harley didn't look at the
clock before look see this cape this is
a complete complete travesty the way it
donor the way it was playing oh my god
yeah anyway so yeah here yet to go
Bishop g7 and this isn't all that much
but after this wide wins I just have to
play it correctly a g5 ok this was
better just keeping keeping the keeping
everything yeah maybe I mean black is
completely stalemated so probably that
was better and it was easier to play I
was just thinking that this should win
because I breakthrough which thus in
fact isn't that easier he has all those
checks I thought I just win this but I
don't check check ok this is just to
complete when you took some on the
Ironborn pawns check check that I
realized I one here four seconds on the
clock yeah so let's see him start here
yeah that wasn't that was a really nice
game showing how wide should play this
always keeping keeping something but
this is still it was very solid still
probably this wasn't the best then King
g3 is better and and this is really a
lot easier of course this is the the
routine with envy three just keeping
everything I just thought that if I go
g5 that would be it would be even more
forceful he's basically stalemated that
if you check Chang this is completely
pointless because this is basically
trapped so after this he has to play
like some some nothing moves and this is
probably an automatic win something here
here whatever like a stalemate at him
yeah it would have been easier I was new
had more time and I absolutely had not
on the ratio that I could lose on time I
mean I spent 20 seconds looking at this
channel out as nonsense but I should
have just made moves that okay thanks
for watching